Générique
- Alexandre Poussart: Bonjour à
tous.
Très heureux de vous retrouver
pour un nouveau numéro de
"Parlement hebdo".
- Kathia Gilder: Nous accueillons
cette semaine Danielle Simonnet.
Bonjour.
Vous êtes députée La France
Insoumise de Paris.
Merci d'être avec nous.
- Alexandre Poussart: Nous allons
refaire le film de la semaine.
Certaines propositions de loi ont
commencé à être examinées.
Le projet de loi d'orientation du
ministère de l'Intérieur poursuit
son chemin à l'Assemblée
nationale.
Il augmente les moyens des forces
de l'ordre.
Au Sénat, trois textes budgétaires
au programme cette semaine.
Le budget de l'Etat, le budget de
la Sécurité sociale et la rallonge
budgétaire face à la hausse des
prix.
- Kathia Gilder: C'était un peu la
semaine de votre groupe.
L'Assemblée examinait les
propositions de loi de LFI au
titre de la journée réservée de
l'ordre du jour à votre groupe.
Petit résumé.
- Plus de 10 textes discutés en
commission et un seul succès pour
les Insoumis.
Seul leur proposition de loi
constitutionnelle garantissant
l'accès à l'IVG et à la
contraception a été adoptée.
Elle était défendu par la
présidente du groupe.
- La France s'illustrerait comme
une nation pionnière en la
matière.
- Aymeric Caron voulait interdire
la corrida.
- Vous cherchez toutes les excuses
que vous pouvez et vous cherchez
ces excuses pour vous cacher.
Il y a une seule question qui vous
est posée aujourd'hui: est-ce que
vous êtes favorables à la torture
animale?
- La majorité des députés
Renaissance sont contre cette
proposition.
Pas non plus de SMIC à 1600 euros
ni d'allocation d'autonomie pour
les jeunes ou encore de
réintégration des soignants
non-vaccinés.
Clémentine Autain n'a pas réussi à
imposer sa proposition de loi
contre la concentration des
médias.
Quant à vous, Danielle Simonnet,
les députés ont refusé votre
demande de commission d'enquête
sur le rôle d'Emmanuel Macron dans
l'implantation d'Uber en France.
- Kathia Gilder: Vous avez fait 12
propositions.
11 d'entre elles vont être
examinées en commission avec une
seule adoptée, celle de Mathilde
Panot, la présidente de votre
groupe.
On dit que cette loi pourrait être
votée notamment par les députés de
la majorité.
Est-ce que ce serait un symbole
fort pour vous?
- Danielle Simonnet: Oui, inscrire
dans la Constitution le droit à
l'IVG et à la contraception, ce
serait quelque chose de très fort.
Si la France l'inscrit dans sa
Constitution, elle sera pionnière.
Ce serait le premier pays à le
faire.
Les menaces de remise en cause du
droit à la contraception sont
imminents dans plein d'endroits de
par le monde, y compris en France.
Rien n'est acquis pour toujours.
- Kathia Gilder: La majorité a
déposé aussi un texte d'Aurore
Bergé.
Le vôtre a été examiné avant.
- Danielle Simonnet: On était dans
l'état des commissions.
Nous avons voté le texte d'Aurore
Bergé.
Notre texte a aussi été adopté.
Il sera présenté en premier.
Le nôtre inscrit le droit à
l'avortement et le droit à la
contraception dans la
Constitution.
Nous interpellons néanmoins le
gouvernement pour que le droit à
l'IVG et à la contraception soit
bien inscrit dans la Constitution
sans passer par un référendum.
Il faudrait pour cela que le
gouvernement prenne l'initiative
d'un projet de loi.
Pour cela, vous avez la réunion du
congrès.
On n'y est pas encore.
Pour que ces textes obtiennent
l'assentiment d'une majorité de
parlementaires, on estime que le
gouvernement doit prendre ses
responsabilités.
- Alexandre Poussart: Vous
demandez un projet de loi car
c'est une proposition de loi
constitutionnelle.
Il faut que le Sénat l'adopte dans
les mêmes termes.
Certains trouvent que c'est un
texte symbolique qui n'a aucune
efficacité juridique.
Que répondez-vous?
- Danielle Simonnet: C'est
important d'inscrire des droits
fondamentaux dans la Constitution.
Cela permet aux femmes de disposer
de leur corps, d'être libres, sans
que cela ne soit remis en cause au
détour d'un texte de loi.
C'est aussi la notion d'inscrire
la gratuité de l'accès à l'IVG et
à la contraception.
Le gouvernement, s'il fait adopter
un projet de loi, à ce moment-là,
nous n'avons plus besoin d'avoir
recours au référendum.
Vous auriez tous les groupuscules
d'extrême-droite qui pourraient
créer une ambiance néfaste pour le
débat sur nos droits fondamentaux.
- Kathia Gilder: Vous avez déposé
une proposition de loi pour créer
une commission d'enquête
envers Emmanuel Macron sur les
dossiers Uber.
Emmanuel Macron était alors
ministre.
Vous attendez que l'on dénonce un
modèle contraire à l'intérêt
républicain supérieur?
- Danielle Simonnet: On se demande
comment cela a pu être possible
qu'une plate-forme américaine
s'implante en France en bafouant
les lois de la République, en
organisant de la contrefaçon de
taxis.
Ils ne respectent pas le code du
travail et ils font un lobbying de
dingue pour pouvoir faire en sorte
d'imposer l'état de fait à l'état
de droit.
Ce sont des pratiques
problématiques.
Il y a aussi dans ce contexte une
activité agressive d'Uber dans son
lobbying.
Les travaux des journalistes
révèlent qu'il y a eu au moins 17
rencontres non inscrites à
l'agenda entre le ministre de
l'Economie de l'époque, Emmanuel
Macron, et des hauts dirigeants
d'Uber.
Il faut aussi se préoccuper des
conséquences de l'ubérisation.
- Alexandre Poussart: Certains
députés disent qu'on ne peut pas
juger l'action passée du
président.
- Danielle Simonnet: Certains sont
très attachés au passé et à
l'histoire de leur monarque
présidentiel.
A partir du moment où l'enquête
parlementaire est une enquête, on
n'est pas dans une enquête
judiciaire, on peut démontrer
qu'il y a des zones d'ombre.
Les 17 rendez-vous non inscrits à
l'agenda n'étaient pas illégaux
par rapport à l'ordre judiciaire.
L'objet de l'enquête doit être de
voir quelles sont les
recommandations possibles à mettre
en place pour faire en sorte de
mieux organiser la séparation des
lobbys et de l'Etat.
Il faut une délibération générale.
Il ne faut pas dépendre des
lobbys.
On doit se protéger.
On voit que la loi est
insuffisante.
Il faut agir là-dessus.
Ensuite, il y a le rôle des
députés.
Ils doivent contrôler la façon
dont les gouvernements gouvernent.
Il faut donc d'abord faire une
enquête sur le lobby d'Uber et sur
les actions d'un ministre à
l'époque.
- Alexandre Poussart: Louis Boyard
a été insulté par Cyril Hanouna
dans son émission sur C8 alors
qu'il venait critiquer Vincent
Bolloré, propriétaire de la
chaîne.
Une commission d'enquête porte sur
la concentration des médias dans
les mains de quelques industriels.
Pourquoi avoir proposé une
commission d'enquête qui avait
déjà été réalisée l'an dernier par
le Sénat?
- Danielle Simonnet: La scène est
hallucinante.
Vous avez un député de la
République qui, interrogé sur la
question de l'immigration, insiste
sur les causes et parle de la
responsabilité des milliardaires
dans l'exploitation des richesses,
le pillage et les catastrophes
écologiques.
Il cite le cas de Vincent Bolloré,
mais on est sur la chaîne dont
Vincent Bolloré est le premier
actionnaire et le patron.
Vous avez le présentateur qui
empêche le député de pouvoir
s'exprimer démocratiquement sur
cette question.
On ne peut pas lui permettre
d'aborder cela.
Monsieur Hanouna explique qu'il
est là pour défendre son patron.
La concentration des médias fait
que vous avez 9 grands patrons qui
possèdent la plupart des médias.
- Kathia Gilder: Les députés de La
France Insoumise doivent-ils
boycotter certaines émissions
comme TPMP?
- Danielle Simonnet: Hanouna a mis
la barre très haut dans l'insulte,
dans l'irrespect et dans le côté
censure.
Le boycott est rarement une
solution.
Si vous décidez de boycotter
toutes les chaînes qui sont tenues
par des milliardaires, on ne va
plus nulle part.
D'un point de vue démocratique,
c'est un piège.
Louis Boyard a raison de porter
plainte pour outrage à personne
dépositaire de l'autorité
publique.
Il est député.
Il demande que le débat sur
l'affaire Bolloré puisse avoir
lieu.
Comme nous avons saisi l'Arcom,
Elisabeth Borne a aussi réagi pour
une demande de sanctions.
- Alexandre Poussart: Il y a aussi
l'affaire Adrien Quatennens.
Il avait reconnu des violences
conjugales.
Est-ce qu'il est toujours le
bienvenue dans votre groupe?
Doit-il démissionner?
- Danielle Simonnet: Pour nous, il
ne doit pas démissionner, mais on
discute dans le groupe des
conditions de son retour.
Cela doit lui permettre de
poursuivre son divorce, qui va
forcément être médiatisé à un
moment donné, mais il faut aussi
préserver la parole du groupe et
la poursuite de notre engagement
contre les violences faites aux
femmes.
Je pense qu'on a tous à bien
réfléchir.
Dans un couple, il y a souvent des
tensions et des difficultés.
Il faut avoir conscience que l'on
doit tout faire pour éviter le
passage à la violence.
On peut notamment avoir recours à
une thérapie conjugale.
Il faut faire passer le message
que tous les couples peuvent
éviter de tomber là-dedans.
Les violences faites aux femmes,
ce sont des violences qu'il faut
absolument éviter.
- Kathia Gilder: Il y a une autre
affaire, c'est le financement de
la campagne de Jean-Luc Mélenchon.
Est-ce que cela vous surprend?
Est-ce que c'est la suite logique?
- Danielle Simonnet: On sait que
les choses se poursuivent.
Je rappellerai que la campagne
présidentielle de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon, dont je suis très
proche, si vous prenez les quatre
ou cinq candidats à la
présidentielle, c'est la campagne
qui a coûté le moins cher.
L'enquête va se poursuivre.
Je n'ai pas à commenter chacune
des étapes.
Les mises en examen ne sont pas
encore effectives.
Cela ne présage pas du tout de la
culpabilité ou pas.
Je rappelle que l'on a fait la
campagne électorale la moins
chère.
Par contre, dans le dossier Macron
de sa campagne présidentielle,
pourquoi celle-ci ne fait pas
l'objet d'une étude alors qu'elle
a coûté très cher et que l'on sait
pertinemment qu'il y a eu des dons
de la part de grands patrons?
Pourquoi ça ne suit pas son cours
à ce niveau-là?
- Kathia Gilder: Une loi prévoit
15 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires pour la police et
la gendarmerie.
Gérald Darmanin s'est targué
d'avoir le soutien des sénateurs
en présentant son texte.
- Le Sénat a suivi le gouvernement
alors que l'on sait que ça
n'arrive pas toujours.
Il y a eu une quasi-unanimité.
Des amendements de tous les bancs
ont été adoptés.
Nous avons fait voter un texte qui
prévoit 15 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires sur 5 ans et qui
je crois est très attendu par
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens.
- Kathia Gilder: Gérald Darmanin
se félicite d'avoir beaucoup de
soutien de beaucoup de députés,
mais pas forcément des bancs de
gauche.
Vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec
plusieurs dispositions, notamment
la création de peines encourues en
cas d'outrage sexiste.
Pourquoi avez-vous voté contre?
- Danielle Simonnet: Ce n'est pas
en augmentant les amendes que l'on
résout les problèmes.
C'est un texte de droite, c'est
logique qu'il soit soutenu par la
droite.
Dans ce texte, il y a le recours
aux amendes forfaitaires
délictuelles.
Cela nous inquiète beaucoup.
On a bataillé à l'Assemblée
nationale là-dessus.
Au départ, ils voulaient mettre en
place 3400 délits en amendes
forfaitaires délictuelles.
Cela veut dire que vous ne passez
pas devant un juge.
Vous n'avez donc pas droit à la
défense.
Il n'y a pas d'individualisation
de la peine.
En plus, Gérald Darmanin et le
groupe Renaissance ont rajouté
certaines dispositions, comme les
entraves à la circulation et
l'occupation de rond-points.
A quelques semaines de la grande
bataille sur la retraite, où le
gouvernement sait très bien qu'il
y aura des manifestations, il crée
des amendes forfaitaires
délictuelles de 500 à 1600 euros
pour criminaliser les lycéens qui
pourraient occuper leur lycée en
guise de manifestation ou des
écologistes qui occuperaient des
voies contre l'inaction
climatique.
Ce serait aussi des amendes
forfaitaires délictuelles que les
gilets jaunes pourraient se
prendre.
A l'approche de la grande bataille
sur les retraites, on trouve que
c'est une dérive autoritaire
problématique.
C'est un texte de droite.
Qu'il y ait une alliance de droite
autour d'un texte de droite, c'est
hélas un schéma assez classique.
Attention, votre démagogie
réactionnaire, la démagogie de la
droite, ne résoudra rien.
Ce n'est pas en augmentant les
peines que nous aurons une
réduction des délits.
Il n'y a aucun bilan, aucune
analyse produite par le
gouvernement.
- Alexandre Poussart: On poursuit
le marathon budgétaire au Sénat.
Trois textes étaient discutés
cette semaine.
Il y a notamment la rallonge
budgétaire face à la hausse des
prix et le projet de loi de
finances.
Quelle est la position de la
majorité de droite?
- Au tour des sénateurs d'analyser
le budget 2023.
La majorité sénatoriale de droite
et du centre projettent d'amender
le texte afin de contenir les
déficits.
Le rapporteur général du budget
déplore l'incapacité du
gouvernement à le faire depuis la
période Covid.
- Les conditions de financement de
la France ne sont plus les mêmes
que par le passé.
Le temps de l'argent facile et
gratuit est bien fini.
Ce n'est pas faute de vous avoir
mis en garde.
- Nous voulons tenir nos objectifs
de réduction des déficits et de la
dette et nous tiendrons les
objectifs qui ont été fixés de
baisse de la dette à partir de
et de retour sous les 3% de
déficit en 2027.
- Le second projet de loi de
finances rectificatives a été
adopté au Sénat également.
Les sénateurs n'ont pas entravé le
gouvernement pour les mesures en
faveur du pouvoir d'achat des
Français.
Autre texte clé adopté au Sénat:
le budget de la Sécurité sociale.
Les sénateurs, inquiets pour le
pronostic, ont voté leur version
du texte avec des modifications de
taille, comme l'ajout d'une
nouvelle taxe sur les mutuelles et
le report de l'âge légal à la
retraite à 64 ans.
- On ne peut pas faire payer aux
générations futures les errances
de nos générations.
Nous devons travailler plus dès
aujourd'hui.
- Le gouvernement planche déjà sur
une réforme retraite.
- Reste à savoir ce que le
gouvernement gardera des
modifications sénatoriales.
- Alexandre Poussart: Le Sénat a
voté sa propre réforme de la
retraite, un départ à la retraite
à 64 ans.
Il y aura une nouvelle lecture du
projet de la Sécurité sociale à
l'Assemblée.
Finalement, c'est le même projet
qu'Emmanuel Macron.
- Danielle Simonnet: Il y a une
alliance qui se fait entre
Emmanuel Macron et Les
Républicains.
On voit que la politique de ce
gouvernement est une politique de
droite, une politique autoritaire.
Sur la question des retraites, il
faut absolument que celles et ceux
qui nous écoutent comprennent
qu'il n'y a aucune nécessité
économique de reporter l'âge de la
retraite à 64 ans.
On nous dit qu'il faut faire
une économie de 8 milliards d'euros
mais la suppression de l'impôt
sur les entreprises
de production lui a fait perdre
des recettes de 8
milliards.
Ils ont fait un cadeau de 8
milliards au patronat,
généralement aux grandes
entreprises, pour finalement faire
payer leur système de retraite et
leur régression sociale.
- Kathia Gilder: Elisabeth Borne
annonce de nouvelles aides,
notamment une nouvelle aide sur le
carburant pour la moitié des
ménages français, notamment les
travailleurs qui font de longs
trajets.
Sur le principe, vous ne pouvez
pas être contre.
- Danielle Simonnet: Tant mieux
s'il y a un peu de respiration sur
le pouvoir d'achat, mais on ne
sait pas jusqu'à quand ça va
durer.
Bloquer le prix de l'essence à
1,40 euro, c'est la seule bonne
mesure à prendre d'urgence.
A chaque fois que vous faites des
ristournes ou que le gouvernement
remet des aides, ça n'interdit
absolument pas les prix de
l'essence de continuer à
augmenter.
Les prix de l'énergie continuent
aussi à augmenter et on a d'une
part ceux qui vont se faire des
superprofits, et de l'autre, le
gouvernement qui prend dans notre
poche.
Pendant ce temps, les autres se
gavent.
- Alexandre Poussart: Le
gouvernement a parlé avec les
producteurs d'énergie.
Total a dit qu'il allait payer les
impôts sur les sociétés.
Les raffineries font des profits
en France.
Tout cela va dans le bon sens?
- Danielle Simonnet: On a
une entreprise qui dégage
des milliards de bénéfices
et qui ne paie pas d'impôts.
Tout cela ne se fait pas sans
hésiter.
On annonce tout cela depuis
longtemps.
On voit que ça va être au rabais.
Ce sera une petite contribution.
Et on attend le bon vouloir du
patron de Total.
Non, il faut redistribuer les
richesses.
C'est la question centrale qui va
provoquer les mobilisations
sociales, notamment celles
déclenchées par la question des
retraites.
- Kathia Gilder: L'Etat veut
freiner la hausse des dépenses des
collectivités locales.
Quand on voit la gestion de
certaines collectivités comme
Paris, notamment Anne Hidalgo qui
a décidé une hausse faramineuse de
la taxe foncière pour renflouer
les caisses, qu'est-ce que vous
répondez?
- Danielle Simonnet: Je suis une
élue d'opposition sur la ville de
Paris, mais pour autant,
l'augmentation peut paraître
exorbitante, mais il n'y a pas eu
de révision de la taxe foncière
depuis des années.
On reste sur un niveau de taxes
foncières inférieure à bien
d'autres villes.
Si on a des petits propriétaires
qui l'ont eue par héritage et qui
ont de faibles revenus, il faut
qu'ils en soient exonérés.
Il faut que ce soit la propriété
où ils résident.
Par contre, les propriétaires qui
sont responsables de la
spéculation à Paris, il faut
qu'ils payent plus de taxes
foncières à partir du moment où la
ville met les moyens sur le
contrôle d'encadrement des loyers,
que ce ne soit pas aux locataires
de payer.
- Alexandre Poussart: On va
regarder l'agenda de la semaine
prochaine.
Au Sénat, toute la semaine sera
consacrée à l'examen du budget de
l'Etat pour 2023.
- Kathia Gilder: A l'Assemblée,
c'est parti pour l'examen du
projet sur l'énergie.
- Alexandre Poussart: Fin de cette
émission.
Merci beaucoup.
SOUS-TITRAGE LIVE: RED BEE MEDIA